man we're a good looking group
cool live and live
wait wait
scheduled for 3 13. it is 3 13. go live
now
here we go live
almost in Vivo
oh I gotta turn this down so I gotta use
this for my chat
oh you're on your phone still for my
chat yeah wear your iPad
in my room
that would be better
probably a little bit better what's up
everyone hello
Marvel Overlord fan
Ty spark the spider cosplayer the artist
Luke
Kenneth Eric
KW Justin Beast Angel Elite Anthony what
is up everybody how's it going Chevy
Leonardo hello hello thank you for being
here we're just gonna
I mean I guess we could give it like a
minute until we really dive into it
I wish man you know the stuff I'd be
doing if I could shape shift I'd be rich
Chris
everyone knows Chris I think I'm
law yeah if you if you go down I'm
that's hello
my name is law I'm happy to be here
everyone there you go uh today we're
talking about secret Invasion episode
two
going into spoilers
so I mean I'm trying to think like
there's no like big shock and awe
moments of like just the very end I
think but even that's kind of like more
like what happens next
but yeah it's more of a setup and a
revelation right yeah so no like super
huge spoilers we are going to talk about
episode two but there's nothing like
super crazy about episode two that's
like
you know game changing for the MCU and
if we talk about it we're going to ruin
everything for you that's that's not I
mean you never do no
I there I'm sure there are people out
there but we this is our official uh
spoiler warning so we're diving into it
talking about who's the scroll
I talked about what you would do if you
were a scroll yeah we'll start with that
I I'm I'm just saying I'm shape-shifting
and meeting all of the famous people
that I want to meet just just throwing
that out there okay no I'm getting more
details how is that gonna work easy
shape shifting
yeah right like twice uh you know if
you're trying to talk to Sana and you
know Geo walks away for a bit I'm
shape-shifting into Geo and I'm talking
to Sana
um
well right so I was gonna say what I
think like the better thing would just
to be is like because you can you can
look anyone you look at you can
shape-shift into so you can see people
online so you can just see what what
their manager looks like ship shift into
their manager just to get in yeah and
then once you're in you know it's not
that hard you're a scroll you can get a
pass or something from somebody take it
and just be very confident
I'm very confident we'll get into the
actual
show stuff here in a second but I do
have a question
grow can turn into anything not just
humans
so I'm just going to shape shift into a
fly yeah
via I'm a fly holding a big old
smartphone bigger than my body trying to
film everything
like episode five there's a fight scene
and and one of them just ship shifts
into like a gorilla just starts going to
town well you can imagine they can I
would imagine yeah they can I think it
would be weird if they couldn't I mean I
think I mean we'll probably get into it
but I think we're leading towards like a
super scroll territory which means kind
of like a uh an open an open ability of
transformation right it doesn't
necessarily have to be a a humanoid
creature
um right and like even Graphics says
something like
like I like dogs more than humans right
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'm just like I
wonder if he's ever been a dog that
literally passed me like it came across
I wonder if I wonder if he came a dog
well and that makes it that actually
makes the threat of the scroll a lot
bigger too right it's like oh not only
can the skies themselves as like us but
they can disguise themselves as a fly
and they could get turned into a
bacteria anywhere oh that'd be yeah
that'd be kind of insane
like Beast Boy and like Teen Titans yeah
right yeah yeah before you know like can
is it that is it that like
um what's the word I'm looking for like
robust like their ability I don't know
we haven't seen it yet
um but that would certainly it'll be
pretty cool throw a wrench in the MCU I
feel like if a one million of them are
just like free Rank and transform into
anything right that's gonna be chaos
don't actually exist yeah correct
that's why you can't kill them because
they're so strong right it's like that
how they can survive the nuclear stuff
right they always say that cockroached
like nuclear blast inside no did we just
discover something and scroll are
literally a nuclear plants right like
yeah figured it out scroller real
they're just cockroaches
um well especially with them building
a super scroll essentially is what
they're you know working up to and so in
the comics
it's really interesting because they're
like kind of they're kind of they're
they're kind of touching on this a
little bit with like Groot and
everything like that so like in the
comics the super scroll was made to beat
the Fantastic Four the super scroll was
given the powers of each member of the
Fantastic Four but Amplified so in the
comics the suit the super scroll can
turn invisible use invisibility Shield
stuff like that uh pyro kinetic plus the
flight uh stronger than the thing and
can stretch further than Mr Fantastic
now I that's kind of what they're doing
like with like Groot he's going to be
able to graphics and be able to like
we've seen it right in one of the
trailers he's like stretch it and it
comes out in like a bunch of different
like Limbs and stuff like that I'm
assuming like Cole obsidian was on there
as well I'm assuming that's like the
strength part right like the thing right
and then the extremist is like right
right and then whoa there was there was
one uh else on there
it was a frost giant Frost Giant from
jordanheim
yeah which I would imagine I mean
General ice powers like creating walls
and structures and stuff like that right
right so so Fire and Ice stretching
and strength yeah that's pretty and and
they could very well include other
things that we don't know though yeah
actually it would be cool I love that
approach right I love the approach of
like these you know all these creatures
you've seen all these creatures let's
make a super Scroll of the MCU which is
really cool I mean do I want like
classic uh F4 powers of course right
exactly I love that there's always going
to be a part of me that has like a
purest attitude towards adaptation but
like sure man I can't wait to see what
this if this is leading up to a super
scroll one what you said what other
powers they might add like what other
cool Powers exist in the MCU that could
just fit right into that kind of uh that
that kind of concept I don't know
there's there's tons to work with but
that's probably the most exciting part
of the as someone who loves like Marvel
versus Capcom and the Fantastic
like super scroll happening in live
action hell yeah give that to me that's
funny I have Marvel versus Capcom like
the full arcade machine
I'll probably put it like right here
since I've changed my live setup a
little bit I'll probably have to come in
and put it like right here because
there's nothing there right now and now
you have need to get Turtles in Time
just have like a whole lineup of it yeah
uh well welcome everybody Welcome to
artists welcome okay everybody that's
here uh hello hello hello
um
some people are saying yeah like after
the scroll scroll invasion of secret
regions over like keep grabbing yes I
would love that he's awesome and he's
super cool I don't know if you guys
caught my interview with him but he's a
super cool chill guy let me take a
selfie with him after like it's just
super cool
um but I to your point law I would
actually since the Fantastic Four is
coming up maybe like there is a little
hint of like oh yeah we did take like
some invisible girl's powers like
specimen unknown power and visibility
you know something like that right
something something they were talking
about in the second episode did you get
the specimen
I could easily see that being a
post-credits scene somewhere at the very
end depending how the series ends like
hey we finally got the specimen and it's
like like a
piece of invisible clothing or like
something right like something like
that'd be pretty cool yeah that would be
pretty cool yeah I wonder how far they
are
with that process with a Fantastic Four
I actually heard there's so many
questions around the Fantastic Four well
I heard today Adam Driver and uh Margo
are out they passed
heard oh they passed interesting yes
that's apparently what I've heard and
you know when when you're when you have
those actors
who want so much money understandably
I'm not like knocking them for that at
all but that's just what you that's just
what when you're as big as Adam Driver
Margot Robbie you get a big block right
and sometimes the budget doesn't include
that much money for the main cast right
so sure uh maybe they just couldn't work
it out but I've heard uh Adam and Margo
are they're not they're not going to be
it doesn't mean they can't come back and
say yes okay by me so I would have loved
Margo uh I'm cool with Adam Driver not
taking a read I don't know something
about him he's he's like almost too
famous for me I want to see well right
re-develop on his own but um just a
little connective tissue about uh uh
Kingsley bed of deer he's great in
Barbie oh really yeah he's really he's a
completely different character archetype
than than who and then graphic right and
so like I was watching Barbie and I was
just like this guy's silly as hell and
then he's like kind kind of a no he's
like a straight up badass in in secret
Invasion he's very very cool to watch
yeah that's interesting I actually
didn't know he was in Barbie I'm glad I
didn't yeah I I might have asked him
something about Barbie and I didn't want
to
uh that's interesting does he play like
a Barbie
figure she's he's a Ken he's a Ken he's
like okay he's a Ken alongside like simu
and Ryan gotcha doctor wait was Barbie
good this is so I just want to know was
it good I [__] love that
I love Barbie it was really good okay
we're gonna slice up with that because
this is obviously not the the timer
so weird to me a Barbies are a squirrel
of course there's a connection so okay
wait so going back to that there was a
a part in it where they they specified
like what the the samples were and and
specified something about them and it
said DNA
right yeah whatever
nucleic acid that's what I said that's
the same word I just said you just said
what I said you just repeated it
so DNA
um so I wonder it seems like the scroll
would have to have an actual DNA to
change absorb right absorb right yeah
like maybe maybe you look but not
ability that was actually something that
I was thinking let's say a scroll does
turn into uh Groot that might just be
Vision not necessarily the ability so
the super scroll will be the ones that
are able to transfer and then also adapt
the abilities of what they fuse
themselves with
yeah because maybe there's a reason why
in the first episode when they put him
in their Sheen they say they actually
say like take his body and then they go
now take his mind they have to touch
yeah yeah so maybe that's what maybe
that's I mean why else would they have
the most part of it right right because
I think in Captain Marvel the first one
they were like
didn't they say something like they
could only remember up to like
a few
years or something when they take the
form or something like that right like
they couldn't remember so far back when
they take you yeah somebody
but then if you're with those machines
with the machines it's different
or something you could like get
everything the next level injecting
right like DNA into your bloodstream and
then yeah well we did we did see them
making that massive machine right so
maybe they got to go in there and get
zapped by whatever and
I'm pretty sure and I also wonder if
he's
if he's gonna give that to anybody else
or just Graphics just gonna he is the
super scroll right because he's a new
character right graphic doesn't exist in
the comics right so maybe it's just well
graphic becomes a super scroll and there
you go there's your Comic character
super scroll well even taking a little
snippet from your interview with him
um which now demonstrating that I
watched
um
he said because I did edit that myself
actually yeah yeah but everybody he he
said at one point you know everybody
keeps looking at this character to be
some type of leader to be the god of
scroll to be whatever and he's like he's
not he's in he's in it for vengeance
right so he actually doesn't care about
the other scroll yeah he's kind of
playing this political way to get what
he wants but based off of what the actor
said about the character he's not trying
to create better scroll it would
definitely fit the profile for him to
just be like no this is for me yeah
because he wants to rule the world
he does
well and it's funny because in the
interview I was like you're but you're
doing this for your fellow scroll and
he's like is he though nope and he's
like yeah he did say that he was like
for you yeah and he goes I was like I
want you to have this Theory yeah right
and he was like he he needs people to
think that and I'm like so
well it's interesting because you
already see in episode two you already
see the disconnect even with the people
who were supposedly on a side with the
council he was like basically only one
of those council members which was like
the prime minister of the UK was on his
side it seemed like they were kind of on
you know even the one guy called him
like her like a trade or whatever he's
like you've been working together
everyone else was pretty much like they
were like uh that whole council meeting
was to decide the fate of graphic they
were going to punish him and then it
seemed like he walked out right it
seemed like the UK prime minister
informed him of that meeting and he
showed up and everyone was kind of
against him at first but of course by
the end
I think out of fear right obviously
they're just like yeah right so you
already see and then like the one girl
walked away and I actually like
how he like let her go because she stood
up right well and he was like if I had a
hundred of you I could take on the whole
entire universe so there was like a cool
line right really cool line it was a
really cool line someone going against
him and him realizing like you're
actually spot on with your beliefs but
hey I am taking this planet for myself
so just just go away
that was a hint to like this might be a
dumb Theory but let's go with it if he's
saying something like that like if I had
a hundred of you I could take over the
whole world maybe he wants more Graphics
maybe that's that's like like a cloning
like a cloning not necessarily for all
the Scrolls but the good ones yeah you
know like the elite and he would weed
out just like other dictators of the
past you know weed out the the weak
links in his opinion uh that could be an
interesting
interest I mean if they're playing with
DNA and they're if they're playing with
experimentation already what what's not
to say that that's his uh his motivation
especially if he's not doing it for his
people then who exactly is he doing for
I think obviously is the big question
there right
is it a classic villain wanting world
domination
or is it like a joker thing where it's
like sometimes people just want to watch
the world burn and he's like I just
screw Theory screw Fury screw humans
because he did go into that monologue
about how he basically hates humans and
loves dogs
yeah
and then at the same time you see he
still respects his people certainly
right certain members oh because they
all were screwed right yeah exactly yeah
they're all refugees at the end of the
day right yeah let me just answer some
questions real quick I see a few uh the
artist warned you think the show could
end with Fury losing and graphic slash
the Scrolls winning I I I don't I don't
see how
there I don't see how there's a way that
they could ever figure out all the
scroll there's Millions on earth right a
million you're never figuring out who
because if I'm a scroll and I'm set up
in a pretty tight situation on Earth and
I'm doing pretty well and I'm like life
is good I don't really want to get
involved with the resistance right and I
don't really want to get involved on the
other side as well though you might sit
back for a little bit and say let me see
how this plays out and yeah
right I'm pretty good I'm super strong
as a human because I'm also a scroll
right I can kind of you know maybe I go
be in MMA fighter and win all the
matches and get some money you know it's
like there's there's ways like being a
scroll on Earth has a lot of advantages
like a lot um yeah do do I think
graphics gonna win no because if if
graphic gets what he wants then all the
humans are gone so I don't think graphic
wins
um but I don't think he's gonna lose I
hope he doesn't die
I could see Marvel killing him because
that's what Marvel likes to do yeah he's
a cool character he's a very cool
character and is uh I actually like the
way he portrays his character uh he's
very
what's the word
he's cold he's cold intimidating he's
intimidating he's very confident
yeah
he's very he's unmoving is what I want
to say like in in that whole Council
scene you just like I love analyzing
facial expressions like what's not said
I love that and just his smiles and the
way he looks and the things he does with
his eyes you can tell like everything
they say he's just like he's already
ahead of him he's like you don't get it
I'm in charge like I'm doing what I want
yeah oh what I caused the War that's
what we're doing
yeah like and he bashes the table like
yeah this is war we're going to war like
of course I'm doing all this because
we're going to war so I really like his
character I
I can see Marvel killing him because
Marvel likes to do that I so I don't
really see him fully winning but I think
the scroll are a part of the MCU for
years and years well that was that was
that's the point I think we should pose
because I think realistically there are
obviously a lot of ways this could end
but there are really two options
do the scroll end up offer or
co-existing on Earth they're not going
to be completely annihilated and extinct
they're not going to win right they're
not going to annihilate humans humans
aren't going to say okay let's go to
Mars like right so do they end up off
Earth or do they end up coexisting with
humans I I probably think I would say
both I think some mics it's gonna be
both yeah I think some are gonna say you
know what
again there's gonna be those scroll
they're like yo I'm in the background I
ain't coming out like you know what I
mean to me man right and then there's
gonna be and it kind of depends on Fury
is he gonna stick true to his promise
eventually is he gonna say I screwed up
I'm gonna find you a place to live and
that's that's kind of your that's where
I get to your question Chris it's like
is that Earth
are they going to coexist
because they talked about that in
episode one right
yeah he was like I think he told Talus
like you once believed that humans and
scroll could exist and he's like I still
believe that but they also talked about
that on the train and Nick Fury was like
he must have been killing each other
since they could stand up there ain't no
existence
well
that's just I think it's gonna be
yeah
um but um
it will be a combination because I think
some of them will be okay with
assimilating into this life that that's
the only life that they know how you
know most of these scroll you know they
they have been living on Earth for how
many years now do would they is it
canonically do we know like
at least the blip right like like 90s
passed to the blip right so I mean it's
it's 1990 people five is where this
episode started with the recap in
Captain Marvel yeah but we don't know
how long they have been there
before that for them yeah so in terms of
like winning or losing I mean this is a
six episode series if Marvel's shows in
the past have taught us anything is that
the resolution is going to come fast and
abruptly and it's not going to answer
all your questions oh and then Fisto is
gonna be there Mephisto no this is the
one right this is the show
well just for what you said law like
even when we go into the nuclear
facility in the first episode and
they're like this is we eat our fruit
and we do our thing and we wear our skin
but then they like pan past a bunch of
kids playing soccer not scrollball you
know like because that's what they know
like the kids maybe never didn't live on
earth and that's the sports and the
entertainment they know so there is
definitely a part of many of this girl
that I think has been bound to earth
like even if they go to new skrillos on
a different planet they're bringing
soccer with them you know yeah yeah
that's a great point
well you also have to think about like
mutants coming into the MCU in the
future Scrolls and human like the world
of the MCU civilians are gonna start
looking really really different it's
gonna start looking more like what
guardians of galaxy civilians right like
you know what I mean it should because
there's like the world has changed so
much and there's aliens now like and and
there's superheroes are doing incredible
things and we're gonna have mutants that
have physical mutations it only makes
sense for some of them to assimilate and
and it becomes like
you know that conversation just like how
X-Men was written in the past it was
about discrimination right and so we're
gonna probably get a couple arcs of that
for Scrolls and mutants alike that's
kind of where I see no that's exactly
how I see it too I was thinking about
this the other day I'm like this is
actually a great start for the mutants
because maybe it does end with Co
habitation and it's like yeah guess what
we'd rather them be in our side living
with us in harmony than pretending to be
other people a big bad guy comes you
build scroll up fight right and then
maybe mutants come out and like well if
scroll can come out we're coming out too
you know I mean like well maybe but I I
do think that discrimination part is
going to be a big thing moving forward
whether with the scroll or mutants or
both both I would probably assume well I
love what law touched on because I do
feel like that really is like okay cool
cool series Espionage everything but
that really is the deeper or should be
the deeper plan for Marvel and one of my
biggest questions posed blip that we
something I really liked about Miss
Marvel that I think got overlooked is
what is it like for a normal person
living in a world where superheroes and
aliens exist and they haven't touched on
it as much as I want them to and I'm
hoping maybe Captain America will touch
on that a little bit more maybe we'll
see some of that and like Echo and
Daredevil unlikely but
maybe mutants will be completely
different in the MCU and that will be
that conversion of alien slash Guardians
of the Galaxy scroll and all the stuff
that the world knows saying hey we want
you to live here immigration on a on a
universal scale and then you'll have the
purebred humans who are anti and then
all of the mixed breeds and that really
could be phase seven I hope it is
yeah but then you have to consider like
the fact that they like
looked into Miss Marvel's DNA and
they're like oh you have a mutation
right so it's like right they're they're
I just wonder how they're gonna go about
stating how she got the mutation like
did she get it by coming in contact with
the Bengal or she was able to use the
Bengal because of mutation
also the Bengals probably King
Technology so it's like why does that
have to do you know what does that have
to do with DNA it's there's a lot of
a lot of ways they could go but I do
hope phase seven is that let me poke you
an honestly go ahead
I agree it really should be that would
be such a cool storyline yeah I want to
pose you Warren I really
honest question because I think that
there are a lot of people including into
some level myself who might actually
question
what we want to believe on this
the Bengal Kang mutants DNA Multiverse
regular Earth
does Marvel actually have a plan
connecting all this right now today I I
believe yes I
I think there are things that happen
that make them re like question their
plans right
um because I I know marvel looks at ever
they could be watching our stream right
now
I know they look hire me I will fix
everything
we will fix everything no um I I Kevin
feige once said
I think this was like two years ago
two or three years to worn privately
yeah right this is to him mentioning to
me as I was talking to him
um that whatever they have announced so
for us that would be all the way up to
Avengers uh
Secret Wars they have
five to six years plus
planned out
on top of what they've already announced
so
they have five to six years after Secret
Wars planned out so they have phase
seven and phase eight planned probably
um yeah they set out to 20 30
five yeah we did the math one time in a
video yeah it was like it was out there
it was like 20 30 something yeah uh I
believe that is true I don't but here's
the real question is what does that plan
look like is it a general outline or is
it hey this movie is here this movie is
here this movie's here and in this movie
they're gonna I will do the person in
this movie they're gonna do this and
it's gonna connect here and then
eventually we're doing Avengers versus
X-men and you know
maybe I don't think so I don't think so
yet I think all the way to Secret Wars
yes
but yes well do you think some of that
is changing as we speak like the big
sbcc we're not going let's rewrite the
stuff you were talking about Sub sub
phases kind of on different multi versus
kind of maybe a rising well that's yeah
that's all kind of newer I would imagine
well and you gotta I kind of sometimes
take a new approach to all of this right
it's been a pretty long time since MCU
started fans don't want the same thing
over and over again right right or or if
you do get the same thing over and over
again has to be better and better each
time right otherwise you're sitting
there going like this is the same thing
and it's not as good which I think a lot
of fans have gone through lately yeah
well I feel like we can honestly say
that Marvel does listen right Marvel
does watch out for what the fandom is
saying as a whole does that make them
make decisions differently every single
time maybe not but like to your point
Warren we've been doing this for so long
and people are starting to complain that
these projects are becoming formulaic
right so that's why stuff like secret
Invasion stick out to me all right like
even Miss Marvel sticks out to me it's
because they are they're trying to go
back into kind of that what I loved
about the like older Marvel was the
genre of films you know like it did its
best to try to do a heist film to try to
do like a fan see film to do a war film
and so now it's almost like we have to
lean into that even harder to make it
more interesting again but then to like
to answer your question Chris I don't I
don't know how much is actually like
detailed planning
changes every day right yeah well in the
chat are talking about that right now
um
I I I think I think the changes are a
good thing sorry to interrupt you a lot
yeah but no no notice I I think we're
all on the same page yeah yeah but so
with the with that being different I
I've talked about this a lot Marvel
Studios really I think Disney was part
of this as well pushing Disney Plus
so I think Marvel was probably
outside influences affecting it right
definitely and they were probably doing
more shows than they wanted to do so I
think they planned it out and part of
that plan was we have to do x amount of
Disney Plus shows right we have to do
all this stuff and and so how do we you
know let's connect all of that to the
bigger picture and I think Disney has
had some big changes lately right and
Kevin foggy has come out and said and
Bob iger's come out and said hey
let's take a step back
we're doing too much I get it you're
pushing for Disney plus subscriptions
and all that stuff before but you know
what yeah but let's uh
I don't care if you're watching Bob
and uh I don't care if you are watching
Bob Iger at
Avatar to Premiere but anyways
um
I so I think after that they've they the
changes are because they want to
genuinely make things better not because
they don't have a like a general idea of
what they're trying to do I just think
and maybe sometimes that does happen
maybe there's a spark of genius that's
like yo what if what if this did this
and this and maybe like oh my God hold
up do that rewrite the entire series
like that's amazing I'm sure that
happens what if we made the Bengals
Kings Bangles like oh snap oh
Tangles I like it instead of the quantum
banster Kings big let's do that yeah
like yeah yeah no I'm sure stuff like
that happens all the time but I do think
overall Marvel does have a a plan I
think where they're at right now so
wherever we're at right now they do have
detailed planning done for like the next
two sagas and then after that it's like
probably like General bullet points yeah
yeah
so anyways Christmas
um to squirrels I think there are two
big questions from the show that we
haven't quite addressed that probably
will require addressing
um Roadie yes and
Fury's wife so those are the two biggest
things right does does Fury know his
wife is a scroll
right yes uh I I think he does there's
actually a part
because you know me I look for details
there's a part in the beginning where
Fury is talking to all the scroll it
shows uh Vara
with her hand on graphic there's a ring
on her finger
it's her right hand but scroll maybe
don't know the freaking difference of
where to put your wedding ring on right
that might be a a foreign thought to
them but there is a ring on her finger
maybe they're already married at that
point in time in Winter Soldier Fury
said he was married
I had a wife he's like there's a lot of
things you don't know about me like my
wife is a scroll like yeah yeah so
I think because I think he knows it
would be a but that would be a pretty
big twist if he didn't
I think because of I think he has to
know but I think because of the nature
of the reveal because it was so
nothing he was walking in the house put
on your ring she was a squirrel she
wasn't a squirrel there are a lot of
questions sure
um is nefarious Crow does he know she's
a scroll what has he been like ignoring
her for the last many years that's the
big thing it's like was she on speaker
like what's going on babe like what's
for dinner like yeah I haven't seen you
and beyond that another question is is
that the same Nick Fury that we're
following how many Nicks well that's
that's actually something that I think
we're I don't know what we've seen so
far but definitely something I think
we're gonna get into like we've seen the
trailers of like Nick Fury blowing up
like the president Convoy and stuff like
that like
um that seems like a scroll thing to do
right obviously yeah their biggest
problem and get you know no offense of
our scroll audience out there sorry
scroll but it's very very strong I don't
care that you're watching nah we're all
canceled for being prejudiced against
scrolling against
the dang cockroaches they call them
cockroaches
[Music]
yeah right turn into this I need you to
look like this today yeah right I mean
it would be it would be a pretty good
writing if he didn't and she was like
actually she was actually a spy
if she was pissed off at him as well
and actually actually well interesting
because if he doesn't because if he
didn't know she were a scroll then any
scroll could take the form of his wife
anybody really know about his wife
that's like secret
maybe someone did
mer so when Hill I mean we're talking
about spoilers when Hill dies what
dies sorry you got to imagine a scroll
maybe touched them and maybe got her
mind and maybe had some secrets so what
if you know what if Fury married a human
and that scroll was planted and he
doesn't know his wife is actually dead
or captured like that's also an option
right um that would also be really
interesting writing
um I don't know where it's gonna go
there's just like not enough information
because it's also like what is what is
the purpose right right yeah none of us
knows the purpose of her being a scroll
um and like Nick is in disarray right
now so it's also like how would he react
at this point in his life he just lost
his best friend right right and like
Confidant he's he's got fired by Roadie
of all people maybe Roadie
um and I don't know it's just it's it's
interesting place to leave episode two
but then I'm like my Logistics goal side
of my brain it's like we only have four
more episodes to wrap all of these
storylines up what's the easiest answer
right yeah and that's it that's actually
a good point they you know
but then again
it's a story about Nick Fury really
yeah well that's more than anything it
is right yeah no that's what it is this
is a story about Nick Fury it's his War
I think that the answer to that question
will be addressed pretty quickly in
episode three I think so too I I think
if he doesn't address the fact that
she's a scroll to the screen then maybe
he doesn't know but I think that that'll
be addressed pretty quickly well
obviously the fact that he has a wife
and they're showing him going home and
he's and she's like hey put on your ring
like that's a big thing they're not just
gonna skip over that like they have to
yeah they just throw that detail in and
then never bring it back up right yeah
everyone in the MCU have like that works
for the government do all of them have
secret wives in their secret houses
right yeah you know Hawkeyes Roadie or
you you know what's going on Steve might
have one yeah who's Roadie with right
now
Fury's wife
gosh he's like
this is where we're gonna
this is where I'm
unsure of Chris is very positive
I wonder about you law law will ask you
first is Rodeo scroll no I want to ask
the chat too is Rodeo scroll definitive
I don't if I need a definitive answer
from you today I I think
I want him to be a scroll if I can say
that I think I would love to see Rody be
a school because I know he has his armor
Wars movie coming and so it would be
almost like a Redemption tour to like
clear his name if he was like you know
trying to get on the good graces of the
public and no one knew he was a scroll
I don't know it's it's like really vague
right now
um I also think he regular Roadie is
very capable of speaking to Nick Fury in
the way that he spoke to him you know
like like first of all Cheadle and
Jackson did a stellar job on that
sequence yeah such a good scene probably
some of the stronger dialogue we've seen
in an MCU TV show
um and it might just be a testament to
both of them as actors but I I'm so torn
and I would love to hear both of your
guys's defenses for why he is or is not
because I I really could go either way I
could see the story utilizing I mean he
has or maybe this is the same thing I
said maybe there's two of him out there
that's also that's also a big
possibility which is really cool I like
that hold on let me answer uh a Super
Chat real quick what's up Joe Bucky
Barnes and TL what's up Warren and gents
Murray Hill isn't dead
the comics have some cool stuff that
could reveal what Nick Fury does in the
comics everybody comes back all the time
yeah
nobody dies right yeah I I think for
movies it's different because it will go
back to what 2018 there are three days
uh but but that's actually going back to
Lost Point going to your point Joe thank
you for that super chat so bad
um thank you Joe uh so much I said so
bad so much um I'll see you so bad I'll
see you next week actually Joe
um but um or maybe a couple weeks but uh
the ambiguity of the show where it's
like you we have no idea and I do like
the fact that it's like one minute you
can see a scene and it's like the real
person and then the next scene it could
be a scroll disguised at that person as
that person that's like a cool thing to
me and at but at the same time like
going into the writing you can't make it
too confusing
right yeah because everyone in this chat
right now you guys on the stream with me
this is what we do we dive into the
stuff we watch YouTube about this stuff
the general public doesn't do that you
know they might Google something and
maybe YouTube Pop video pops up or
something like that or an article comes
up but most of them are just that's why
we exist to explain it to them when they
don't know exactly but they're not
watching every video we do right they're
just that's on them that's their fault
that's your fault people sounds like a
you guys we're right y'all are not
um but no but you you still can't be
that confusing because that'll turn
people off right so I I hope to see some
of that not too much of that but I do
hope to see some of it like I hope I
hope it's a scroll Nick Fury shooting of
RPG at the presidential Convoy because
that that's good storytelling like a
scroll disguise himself as Nick Fury to
get Wars everyone and Nick Fury is
killing School president that too right
and that's a that's the cool part about
it it's like you really don't know I
don't know maybe Fury or uh roady's
there and Fury's proven a point he kills
the president he's like look I told you
the president was a scroll Nick Fury is
killing a skull president not knowing
that the president's a scroll because
they don't know and he's trying to blame
Nick Fury but redeems Nick Fury because
they find out the president is a scroll
and Mephisto is in the plane I'm just
kidding and Brody is Mephisto
this whole time and now he finally has
an Ironman technology all to himself
he's the only Iron Man now he's War
Machine and he's keeping it and he's
keeping it he's keeping it
well we just figured out the outline for
the rest of this year everything right
there
everything well all that Mephisto stuff
about him buying Avengers Tower and all
that I'm
excited to see
everyone's been asking laughing in that
Tower I'm excited to see it too it's
been a long time I've talked about some
of this oh let's take it out yeah I've
talked about some of those spoilers on
our patreon uh oh yeah
um we won't go too deep into it right
now but I have talked about some of
those on patreon because people Wanna
Know
yeah patreon plus I don't know if you
guys are already linked but okay
I'm sure you guys can find it you're all
smart oh you guys typing in the comic
wonder patreon you guys are also smart
and handsome and nice you can go check
out his patreon they're not Scrolls no
plugs
you got a lot of ads in your name and I
don't know how to address that it says
Roadie equals Mephisto
yeah that's put it on a shirt yeah we're
rolling with print them off rhodium
Fisto confirmed you heard it here on the
show first
yeah yeah hire us Marvel
it's interesting I wonder how much uh
Marvel is anticipating audiences tune
into secret Invasion uh and how much
that will affect like the the the story
as a whole because like
Miss Marvel well I I enjoyed it I know
it wasn't everyone's cup of tea but the
the setup at the end is clearly for the
Marvel's movie right so what does secret
Invasion setting up like what is the
like it you know that's like my big
question is in these six episodes what
are they trying to accomplish assuming
because you have to also assume that
people aren't watching this the all the
series right so when Moon Knight shows
up in an Avengers movie some people are
gonna be like who the hell yeah why is
Oscar Isaac in this movie you know what
I mean like the Man story and so they
have to do a good job at Bridging the
Gap that's why like while I didn't love
Falcon in the Winter Soldier I think it
did a really good job like yeah uh
explaining the whole Captain America you
know like the the passing of the mantle
but moviegoers when they watch Captain
America four with Anthony Mackey are
just gonna be like oh yeah end game at
end game old Captain he's Captain
America Rogers gave it to him yeah yeah
yeah just like they'll play so
the new answer to your question yes
um Moon Knight was a scroll that's the
connections
Sam Wilson he's the scroll obviously
every single Disney Plus show that
they've made they've all been scrolled
obviously they're just gonna start
everything over by saying okay it turns
out they were all scroll we just
finished that let's start over you guys
remember how you loved Chris Evans as
Captain America oh yeah
oh by the way we're bringing Robert down
a junior back oh you thought Tony Stark
was Tony Stark scroll oh no he was been
a scroll the whole Jarvis yeah
[Laughter]
Ultron
series eye patch was a scroll oh gosh
um
for whatever reason yeah
he's owning it now yeah I I to answer
your question
I think what secret Invasion should do
is one set up a premise for mutants but
two kind of sh and Chris think talk
about this a little bit too kind of
shake up the Earth to make them realize
like hey there's a lot out there yeah
you guys just don't know and it seems
like the rest of the planet is one a
little bit more advanced because you see
like a lot of these species gathered at
like nowhere and it's like you're all
from different places right but you're
all perfectly fine with each other like
you see other species all the time where
humans are like oh my gosh there's
aliens in the air what like what where
the Avengers at it's like there's so
much other stuff out there
so I hope this actually starts like a
big shake up for earth I agree with them
like realizing like hey they're scroll
hey there's mutants hey hey there's a
Giants
exactly right exactly I think I think it
is starting
to yeah I think that's starting right it
started with the first Avengers with a
big giant space portal and everything
like that and but it gets even bigger
now where it's like hey
there's so much out there and there's
actually a lot here there's millions of
aliens that have been here for years for
decades yeah yeah so that's what I think
I hope it does yeah to that point I
think the MCU right now in this day and
age is best when it leans into all the
weirdness that it has at its disposal
like the uh werewolf By Night movie that
was that was awesome it was great and
like I really liked eternals I think it
was it was cool to get like the weird
Cosmic side of the MCU you know and now
I I explained this to friends before who
are like oh I'm kind of over the MCU
it's because they're not naturally like
comic book readers right and so the MCO
up until the point was all about enjoy
like a whole audience enjoying like a
Blockbuster movie but now it's getting
real nerdy yeah really cool to me
because it's like we're branching out we
can be extra Cosmic we could be extra
sci-fi uh we could go into horror and so
when you when you don't fully commit you
get something like quantumania where
it's like where it's like just fine and
I think MCU is best when it just like
lean into like the craziness yeah and so
that's that's why the mutants the
Scrolls all that stuff it needs to be we
just need to see that shake up I I hope
that's where it's leading because that's
exactly what I want yeah and I'm one of
those people and like this is just I
always get like torn apart oh just my
opinion man what's up dude how's it
going yeah I always I always get kind of
tore up for this but it's like genuinely
how I feel
and it's changed a little bit over time
but
it's hard for me to really hate a movie
it really is so what I have to do now is
I have to watch a movie at home
because I'm a person who loves to go to
the movies and I love the experience of
the movies and like eating popcorn and
all this stuff that affects the movie it
affects how I feel about a movie so I
have so I've gotten to the point where
it's like I have to sit at home and
watch something to kind of fully digest
how I feel about it bootleg on his phone
The Flash yeah these Graphics are bad
news
without even texting you law the other
day I was like I actually really like
the Flash and I tweeted it out
everyone's like you're kidding right I'm
like why like why is it why is it that
bad and don't get me wrong I can I can
see in as like the MCU is concerned like
I can see how people are frustrated and
I myself have I've dogged on some shows
like did not like She-Hulk I won't watch
what if season two so don't expect that
for me I just won't do it what if I
hated what if season one
um
I don't know why but but I did and yeah
there were there were some movies that
have been subpar for me but I've I've
never once thought like the MCU is dead
and again I get flagged for it because
it's obviously like well you talk about
DMC every day of course you can't
believe it's dead because then it's like
what are you gonna talk about I could
talk for your boss
turning into a K-pop Channel why we'll
talk about that for hours right yeah uh
I could talk about anything
years and days I love how people are
like
you you make your videos just at the
eight minute Mark I'm like you realize
how long my videos actually are and are
cut down to Shorter it's like do you
kidding me like I could just I could
talk for hours
I'll get texts for more and it'll be
like uh I don't really have time to do a
full video today I think I'm just gonna
do like a two three minute video so I'm
sitting there like oh oh it comes it's
like 10 minutes long I'm so sorry I'm
like I do that actually find the two
best minutes good luck yeah all right I
I do I'm I'm like I'm like yeah I'm
trying to do like a pack one real quick
it's like 20 minutes
it's like as it turns out I had a lot
more to say about the subject than I
thought it turns out I'm very
opinionated yeah because I don't a lot
of people don't know this but I don't
script my videos like I have bullet
points usually when I go in but then I
just talk and just comes out yeah yeah
which I think is also why people watch
is because there's like a natural
Cadence to it you know when when
someone's reading off of a script I
usually click away from those go ahead
hello
I am not a scroll welcome back Nick Fury
is awesome
Nick Fury is not a scroll scroll do not
exist
cockroaches with boots that's right none
of us uh yeah to answer I see some
people saying like oh you hated what if
uh
I'm sorry when people put like symbols
and stuff in their names it's hard for
me to pronounce
um but uh philosophy that's what it is
okay philosophy yeah uh I
I I think I jokingly say I hated what if
like I did not enjoy it though I will
say that like I I sat through watching
them and I was just kind of like
in the same vein that people don't like
the comics you know like people don't
like the what if story
lines because they're too bizarre and I
just they also don't have any weight
they don't matter yeah true right yeah
exactly right this is all theoretical
hypothetical
yeah yeah hello read
the chat hello
hello
maybe you could use some work it's Joe
ho The Avengers are gone Who the hell's
going to fight the super scroll in
season finale
well you think Talos is a good guy
so are you asking if I actually think
Talos is Talos or it's a scroll
disguises
man I didn't even I didn't even think of
it that deep I
thought you've ruined it all
like it's a scroll Taylor's pretending
to be a squirrel Talos
that's too much who's gonna fight the
super scroll with any luck it's Carol
Danvers and then they just wrap this up
Iron Man okay here here's the here's a
theory I love because I loved Agents of
Shield I don't know if you guys watched
that which I did yeah I F in love that
channel yeah and I love I know it's not
canon it sucks but what if they did a
soft reintroduction and like one of the
super scroll DNA abilities was Quake was
Daisy Johnson people keep talking they
had Daisy returning yeah I would love to
see that I know Chloe Bennett's already
denied it but she's my she's like one of
my top celebrity crushes she called me
beautiful ones at a red shirt they're
probably watching right now say hi hey
Chloe oh Chloe hey oh I'm sorry I don't
think about that moment I don't think
about that moment all the time and
re-watch the video over and over again
no not me that doesn't happen oh
but like I would like to see some kind
of team up for the super school because
you're that's a good point face Master
says she means scroll Carol Danvers oh
God
what have we done did anything is
possible now in any barns yeah Bucky
Barnes with the highlighted message
uh Halos is the big bad yeah so yes
Scrolls oh wait hold on so juico Vico
West Side says can Scrolls mimic other
Scrolls I almost said an affirmative yes
because we see the trailer where we see
many Graphics we see the scroll turning
the graphic but they're actually human a
human
yeah so I don't know
we don't know if they could turn into a
fly or not I'm thinking yes I don't see
why they their unique ability would to
only be to move can you could could a
scroll
shriek its atoms to get that Smalls if a
scroll turned into yeah but 11
well we saw we saw the guy turn into
like a shorter lady I don't know like I
mean look at the graphics yes the
graphics that little girl and then a guy
and a girl yeah yeah yeah and Nick Fury
like they're changing up and down they
changed their clothes in the in the same
way that running is exertion right I
imagine those Transformations that
aren't just like face and whatever that
probably does uh that sounds like
something a scroll would say
loss of scroll confirmed
I would love to be a scroll you guys I
would love the musical too strong and
then if you're telling me I could be
taller I'll just be a taller version of
me at all times and I'll disguise myself
oh God so in the same way as super
scroll can use different abilities at
one time could I make my body like
uh like someone cooler looking and then
keep my face so it's still me ah I'm
imagining you could turn into whatever
you wanted to
the way I'm talking right now is proof
that I'm not a scroll
or or are you just trying to Super
convince us
also thank you again Bucky Barnes for
that Super Chat Taylor says the big bad
just watch
but it's Taylor's Talos as the big bad
but it's Taylor's Talos that's the
question that's that's what we're gonna
ask every single episode
is roadie roadie
is president president
Shooter McGavin
there we go
[Laughter]
um
yeah with the Scrolls start appearing in
different movies
um well you've seen the promotions for
the show yeah where they're like showing
up on news they show up in like real
life news like people are discussing
them in the background actually on on my
podcast we just interviewed one of the
makeup artists who designs all the
scroll makeup and he was he was going
around to different places and just
putting scroll makeups on people to like
just go to offices like No cameras
around just like to be a scroll at the
Disney offices like stuff like that I
just like damn that's a lot of money for
some secret promotion
let's dive down this because I think
it's actually pretty curious Talos is
the big bad what's he trying to gain
I mean it's the same thing as graphic
it's pissed at Fury
you think so like he's turned on Fury no
I don't I'm sorry I don't agree with you
Joe I don't think Talus is the the big
bad if he is I don't think he's Talos
Talos why did you change that change
that it's Talos now I know they say it
both ways they do they do they say it
prefer Talos
Taylor Swift this is like Thanos Thanos
Taylor Swift is a scroll
I would believe that
there's actually some I've actually like
seen a pretty crazy theory about Taylor
Swift and there's like
uh photos of like people like like
impersonating no like there's there's
there's photos of her like decades and
decades and decades and decades ago
it's like oh she's the Illumina part of
illuminati she's like
transferring like she's not she's
Immortal stuff like that anyways
scroll confirm pretty much is all I'm
saying yeah no I I don't I don't think
I don't think Talos is the big bad I
think graphic is just really set up
perfectly to be the Super scrolling to
be the big bad and yeah
yeah go for it I think it probably would
take Carol Danvers to come down
to beat a super scroll because fearing
clearly doesn't want to call The
Avengers because he's afraid that
someone's gonna shape-shift into them I
mean and yeah and and also
it's always going to be the question
also to that fact
are any of the Avengers currently scroll
right because that's the big Roadie
theory is that in Civil War he actually
died and a scroll took his place
yeah
so which which would break my goddamn
heart well that's what some one of The
Outsiders said one of the Insiders said
like there's going to be a scroll reveal
it's going to break your heart I don't
think Brody being a scroll would break
my heart but Chris firmly believes he's
not a scroll because it's too on the
head right I think it's too obvious and
I think just based off of Maria Hill
when she sees Fury she's pissed at him
she says what the what the hell like
you're Nick Fury and you did this and
that's not the Nick Fury thing somebody
made a comment
I cannot remember where to save my life
that it's somebody killed Chris Roadie
is a scroll because at some point in
some movie at some point in the history
of Marvel he says we only call him fury
like nobody calls him Nick and he refers
to him has Nick Fury at one point
sitting down at the table fire him and
then the other argument is like he
wouldn't do that like that's out of
character for him but Roadie was also
abandoned by Nick Fury and he's pissed
and he's lost respect for him and that's
demonstrated by him calling him now if
not oh this isn't him acting him this is
him being pissed and he's excited to
fire him because he left Roadie high and
dry he left Maria high and dry I left
Earth I don't know if that's 100 I'm
going to counter that I don't know if
that's 100 true because in the first
episode they're like he's in charge of
this program he can't just leave like
they know he's up there and he's clearly
supposed to be doing something for the
government so but then why is Maria mad
at him for for leaving and disappearing
well she doesn't seem like Alice is mad
that he left and disappeared like he
wasn't contactable he's not like back
business related maybe with Hill
but like because like if you're a
government employer government employee
like I understand that I think to some
level it will be
I mean obviously Fury isn't on top of
his game he is weak he's falling behind
I think you know there's a part of him
that kind of fell off and he abandoned
people who cared about him who you know
naturally in the business of politics
and world saving jobs like they're mad
they're like you you left me as a friend
you left me as a colleague you left me
as a partner and a superhero and I don't
respect you and what you've become and
then I do like Nick Fury's rebuttal to
Rhodes when he's like even when I'm out
I'm in and we have seen moments where
Nick Fury does have that fire of being
Fury and you know smashing The Bodyguard
down and but there is definitely a part
of him that isn't the same that
hopefully we can get back to
yeah
yeah there's lots to think about yeah I
don't know I don't think I'm very
surprised that we haven't figured it out
the second episode I think that's what
makes this show good I actually really
am in the show I'm enjoying it too I
wish the viewership was higher uh but I
don't think it has like the hook that
like
that like other you know Miss Marvel is
a little bit more colorful She-Hulk had
a gimmick of this big green lady we have
a bunch of green people hiding as
regular people I don't know um well it's
supposed to have it's not supposed to
have that tone like it's yeah
I really do too I really do too I missed
this energy from this universe and
that's why I don't know
it works for me the serious tone like
yeah like that's why people like the
Captain America movies because they were
serious like yeah they have their funny
moments and the show has the funny
moments too but yeah
there's a there I think some a lot of
people have complained that the MCU is
really silly
quantumania Thor love and thunder you
know what I mean like there's a lot of
silliness to it and a lot of people have
won and I see a lot of people already
and some people said in the chat like
we want rated R stuff right we want some
really serious stuff and actually in
episode two that shooting and stuff at
the end was pretty you know you're
watching people get shot in the face in
the head you know and you're you watch
her cut the guy's finger off right it's
like it is getting there and I hope
Daredevil is like that and it clearly
will be if they're willing to go this
far in secret Invasion but yeah I I do
enjoy this seriousness of this show I I
really do I mean for the longest time my
favorite MCU movie was Winter Soldier
and now there's so many great movies
it's hard to kind of rank them for me
now right um but Winter Soldier always
creeps up because it had that like
perfect kind of like spy Espionage Vibe
but it was still a superhero movie like
hell yeah give me all that right and
then this is really nice because it's
you get to spend a little bit more time
with all these characters I think it's
shot really like like it shot like a spy
Thriller should be shot and um the
choreography is also really Stellar I
like graphics
scene in like the meat locker or
wherever the hell they were oh gosh that
was so cool to me and um I don't know
there's but there's so many characters
uh it's so hard to
um to make like a definitive Definitive
statement of like where I think this
show is going because like I'm I'm it's
nothing like the comic to me you know oh
it's not just at all for the right yeah
yeah so it's just like yeah we're just
I'm just here till the end man let's
show me what's next
um I think the only thing I can really
say is Graphics gonna be super scroll
yeah I think I think that makes
that's worth leading right they might
not call him the super scroll right but
he's gonna get all those Pat we've seen
the trailers in his arm extending like
groot's arm right so he's gonna get
enhanced in some way right so so if if
Gaia is
if gaia's
on to him I wonder if there's
I wonder to go back to the question like
who takes out the super scroll does she
also make herself a super scroll Maybe
that'd be interesting
um no I don't feel like you're bringing
Emilia Clark for one season
uh yeah that's a good point well Bailey
Clark is uh yeah she's huge but at the
same time so like I I'll bring her back
to wanna vision
we're talking about like Carol Danvers
coming in stuff like that like this is a
show about Nick Fury and and Marvel does
tend to keep the focus on like the main
character right at the end it wasn't
Mephisto and all this stuff right it was
Vision versus vision and yeah Wanda
versus the villain right so
I I think it I think it probably will
just come down to Nick Fury and and
and graphic
and it's really weird maybe he just
finds a way to outsmart him somehow
right but in my mind it would take like
Gaia becoming a Super Squirrel as well
or Captain Marvel coming down or Nick
Fury has got to do some crazy cool spy
stuff to outsmart him and set up a lot
of explosions and stuff like that to
like really kill this guy because I mean
scroll die they get shut and die in the
first episode we saw that right you know
they're not unkillable right yeah so
yeah Nick Fury gets up our fingers
yeah exactly you know Nick Fury gets
enough RPGs going at the same time you
know a bunch of rockets at the same time
like sure the super skull is going to be
harder to kill is he going to be
unkillable no
so I hope they don't call Captain Marvel
and I think that's a pretty easy cop out
in all honesty
I hope Olivia Coleman just shows up and
takes care of everything yeah she's been
great she is so funny like in that scene
that guy and comes in like she's so
funny yeah just her it's her yeah
make your subs guess like
it's so funny it's like oh they all talk
it's just a matter of when it's just
like uh man if you're that guy just like
when a girl shows up like that you're
like all right this girl's gonna she's
gonna make me talk I'm just gonna talk
right now I'm not gonna get hurt like
all right you know what I'll tell you
everything you're smiling too much this
is way too much smile you seem way too
confident you have made a lot of people
talk or have killed them I'm just gonna
go ahead and tell you everything you
wanted
yeah yeah I mean it could be I mean
there's so many characters that could
come in it would make more the most
sense for it to be connected to the
Marvels in some way but of course yeah
who knows I I think what you said is
actually right on the money they do
like this is the problem with every FCU
show people like us get together we
start theorizing and I had no part in
the Mephisto theories at all
then we get to the end and it's like oh
yeah I guess that makes sense because
that was the easiest answer right and so
I'm trying to temper my expectations and
what you're talking about is like Fury
is the main easiest answer
I think it goes back to what you all
said not too long ago like the show's
about Fury exactly the show whether Fury
ends up dying at the end or becoming
Nick Fury again getting his eye patch
and getting back into the place that's
right
I mean one of the biggest things though
is like Miss Marvel like he's there
shaved right looking good with an iPad
this before is this after like where are
we going where what does this bring to
the Future because as much as like you
want to just sit back and enjoy the six
episodes It's Marvel you can't you have
to think Beyond it and that's one of
their biggest burdens moving beyond the
infinity Saga is that expectation of
connection cameos characters and that I
think has been a bit of a struggle for
them to carry that weight because we are
all sitting here like
yeah what what's next where's Iron Man
where's iron but he's coming back I need
um boom like yeah we're waiting for it
and they're gonna deliver hopefully but
yeah well I like we're the hopefuls how
long do we wait
I think the show 's been pretty good and
I think it does have that connectivity
they mentioned the Avengers several
times yeah and all those moments are
like
really cool yeah and they just said the
name like I got the Avengers for my
midlife crisis it doesn't take much to
like satisfy us
yeah you just gotta name drop every now
and then right so I mean my biggest
thing is it's like who's gonna be
revealed to have been a scroll the
entire time
you know is Rodeo scroll Tony Starker
scroll at some point in time like that's
the thing is anybody could have been a
scroll at some point in time
right I think it would be a little the
characters in in the past plot points if
they were like oh yeah like during
Avengers Age of Ultron like
Black Widow is a scroll like it would be
little our character belittle everything
that's happened so I don't think we're
gonna get anything like that but I do
think it's gonna be like oh one point in
time uh Black Widow did this just like
actually nope it wasn't Black Widow we
did it it was this other person nothing
like huge maybe nothing we saw on screen
well the scroll are obviously feeling a
burden
of Nick Fury not keeping his promise and
half of the promise was y'all gonna do
some stuff for me right so that's like
what is that stuff you guys have
obviously we kept up our part of the
bargain like when tell me tell me when
what did you do like so we know stuff
has been going on it's not like they've
just been existing there waiting for
Nick Fury to say okay we'll live here
they've been doing something that's what
they're pissed about
yeah
maybe the Avengers Initiative was a lot
bigger than we thought and there were
multiple adventures in multiple areas I
know I think that's what they're gonna
kind of show us between that and and
Multiverse it's becoming a very
confusing uh world and that's why the
world needs to react to it sorry that
like bringing back that point yeah it's
just so much weird stuff happening in
this world yeah that it's like weird
that no one's like like what you were
saying Chris like we don't see people
reacting to it or like being like oh
this is the aftermath of
a giant Celestial in the ocean right the
aftermath nothing like a giant bomb we
got we got a newspaper clipping in
She-Hulk is that not enough
Wolverine newspaper
right underneath it yeah of the whole
adamantium Theory right right yeah oh
yeah right so it's like
all right it's coming I guess maybe
we'll see and then we will wait Joe
Bucky Barnes ATL Atlanta makes a good
point too thanks for Super Chat the cree
show up question mark they have to right
eventually yeah like they can't just
stay out there right they're they're
gonna show up and I think that's really
going to be addressed in Captain Marvel
because we have uh the daughter of Ronan
coming as the villain right so yeah also
caulkling is very much a possibility I
don't know if you guys liked liked like
the new Avengers or the Young Avengers
and stuff hulkling's half Cree half
scroll yeah so if we're gonna stick with
the Scrolls for the while for a while
yeah that's right we're gonna get Wiccan
back you know like maybe they're the
Young Avengers is actually being built
because like we got America we got
um Haley's in there who knows if Haley
will be a young Avenger but I think it's
stuff I've heard yeah
what
so so we'll see we'll see how it goes
um yeah
uh Spencer liked to answer your question
I don't think any of the Guardians of
Galaxy or scroll no
no no no no no
um
nah
so I want to say one point though but it
is
something just popped up in my head
doesn't happen often
and it might be
it's very likely over analyzing and I'm
just trying to get it all together how
do
the scroll
no Groot
well I I think I mean there's space
Travelers right well that too so do they
just know about the race but or did they
interact with Gru during his very brief
time on Earth I think that because they
were there which means we could narrow
it down to somebody in wakanda when
groups showed up
why would you why would the scroll not
try to infiltrate wakanda
right I mean like you find out about
that yeah absolutely oh yeah I'm going
was somebody there and group dropped one
of his branches and they grabbed it and
brought it back saying somebody was in
battle right I mean I'm sure probably
them got chunked off at some point in
time right I mean he can get a shot and
be perfectly fine
anyone at the end game battle that too
right is fair game you know anyone from
hamartage could have been a scroll that
no sorry yeah and I mean you know like I
said there are probably some scroll that
are probably like you know what Earth's
not bad I'm gonna help him
right yeah and then they were there and
then maybe they had enough after it
right uh but I mean the scroller on the
planet they can't have the planet get
destroyed plus Thanos was a threat to
the entire universe right the year so
it's not even like hey let's save Earth
it's like oh you screw everything else
guys we have to stop Thanos from killing
everybody right well yeah that was more
of a united front right exactly so yeah
and just grabbed a part of group
but it is interesting because it's like
there have there's something that allows
this to either they they've they have it
in their collection because they just
collect DNA because like how they get
into the not the oldenheim What's um
the frost giant Heim that one
yeah yeah like how do they get that like
and extremists is Right obviously on
Earth but it's it's a call obsidian I
mean that's that's again another like
towards end game
straight up his hand so it's like but
was Doctor Strange Things
They kind of dipped after so maybe
they're maybe something let me get this
hand yeah who picked it up yeah I mean I
think a scroll picked up
yeah I mean obviously that's exactly
right yeah but no but law to your point
yeah I don't think it's limited to this
earth I think yeah because because they
have to get the samples do they have
access to rocket ships I guess I don't
know it could just be old samples too
you know like we're gonna bring this
piece of fruit with us we might need it
one day well they they made someone made
a a really great someone just said a
frost giant came to Earth and Thor too
is that true I don't remember I forgot I
mean
technically technically
um
so if they got a little closer what were
you saying sorry
oh what was I saying
what were we just talking about I forgot
space bro with the Scrolls scroll we
were talking about indeed
yeah no it like
Giants
for listening to us we sound good
you said somebody just said a really
great oh there was a line yeah there was
a line where they were saying like we
you know like Scrolls
um they didn't want to like like get
they didn't want to have peace they like
spread War across the galaxies or
whatever I mean
uh something to that effect but like I
like the idea that like Scrolls have
like a really storied history because in
the comics like one of my biggest gripes
with Captain Marvel was like why are the
scroll nice uh because I always just
remember them being their villains
they're the villains and the three were
good yeah and so and so it's it's nice
to see that like one it's like not
retconning but giving more light to like
the spectrum of Morality In The Scroll
Universe I guess right but like but like
I do I do think that they're a
well-traveled race and they just don't
have a home and so it's very very
possible that they have samples from
across the universes you know
yeah
very very very possible you know and I
definitely don't think we should limit
it to just stuff that's happened on
Earth
yeah because we don't know what they did
before they came to Earth we don't
before the cree you know destroyed their
home we have no idea I mean they had
ships Talos left at the end of Captain
Marvel right he slowly comes back but
they did leave you know they they had
they I think they definitely have the
ability to get things off
so
but all right well we're gonna looks
like they're right yeah there was a
frost beast on Earth you guys are right
well we'll have to I'm genuinely curious
see who's gonna be a scroll man like uh
and again somebody might not entirely be
a scroll but some a scroll has
impersonated them at some points in time
true so it's like yeah the the
possibilities really are pretty endless
for this
um
I'm really excited to see where it goes
but hey drop your best thought on who
a scroll is down below Roadie or Nick
Fury actually did die in Winter Soldier
and it is a scroll that took his place
and all of his memory and all the stuff
you know I drop your best prediction
down below and uh we're gonna be back
next week talking uh talking about
episode three so let us know how you're
enjoying secret Innovation 2 and you can
follow
Chris there we go did it on uh Cosmic
culture and his
I don't know your Instagram handles
honest Insurance there you go and you
follow law on a bunch of different
places I'll let you guys said you're say
your best place and you can find me on
most platforms is law J Sharma and
you'll find me yeah
oh you're fine
you'll find me I'll feed you baby birds
don't worry and I don't exist on the
internet so you can't follow me
because you're a scroll but also
subscribe to my Channel right now
patreon on that note let me plug it is
on patreon
no but seriously thank you everybody for
tuning in today thank you uh Joe for
being uh the moderator this time
um
we'll see where it takes us we'll see
where it takes us and I'm sure we're
gonna have a lot of new theories next
week so until then
we'll see you guys